you know that along with the war on
drugs in general is a [ __ ] myth
you know um because you know we were all
told that when you know
when pablo escobar was killed by the de
well that was it right we won
we won the war on drugs this is like
come on like you know
i mean to today i don't know post
pandemic but pre-pandemic
you know uh uh cocaine was um
i think cheaper and almost and and
potentially more
pure than it has ever been in history
and so really
yeah and so what does that tell you
about like supply and demand it means
there's
ample supply which has driven the cost
down and it's
and uh and it's you know they're not
stepping on it i mean i guess depending
on your dealer
they're not stepping on it as much and
and you can get you know you
what i'm saying is if the free market
teaches us anything
it's that it means that i don't think
demand has gone down
i think it's because uh uh i think that
that
uh supply has has uh uh is ample
and that is a failure of the so-called
war on drugs i uh
believe it or not have never done
cocaine i've never done ecstasy
i never smoked pot till about i tried it
i think for the first time in 2017
when i was in denver colorado um where
it's legal
um and uh you're you're not gonna
believe this
or maybe you will believe this i just
got a missed call from george valdez
did you really yeah that's hilarious
yeah but um so uh i think he also said
i don't remember did he say i think he's
also told me i could be wrong but you
can verify this he told me he's never
tried cocaine either
yeah listen a lot of a lot of guys in in
the
sort of the the upper echelons of of
that world were not
big users i think a lot of them it was a
product
that they sold it was not necessarily
something that they you know
it could have been widgets you know like
you know in george's case it started off
as bananas
he was a banana importer and a banana
transporter you know like that was his
product so
it didn't matter um uh to them they
weren't necessarily
fans they were you know i'm i'm gonna go
out on a limb and say the ceo of
mcdonald's doesn't eat mcdonald's every
day you know like
um in fact probably because it's
arguably deadlier than cocaine uh
i would i would think but um you know uh
uh to everyone who is shoving
mcdonald's in their mouth but won't get
a vaccine um like what the [ __ ] are you
putting in your body you know i love me
hey i love mcdonald's coffee bro
i drink mcdonald's coffee almost every
day they have the best coffee
dude but i live in miami we have cuban
coffee and you live in tampa
cuban coffee is the greatest [ __ ]
coffee
full stop that's it i agree
um like i don't know how i'd be
conscious right now
without it well uh going back to the
cocaine thing
adderall is the new cocaine everybody
does adderall now
well that's been going on for a while
but that's like the new thing it's a
performance enhancing drug
and and um it's funny like there's a uh
uh the percentage of i think major
league baseball players
that have waivers to to use adderall
because their other doctor's
recommendation is like disproportionate
to the general population
meaning like apparent apparently a lot
of baseball players have 80
uh adhd which by the way watching
baseball gives me adhd so i don't blame
them
but like but like what i'm saying is
that like that's a performance enhancing
drug
you know like it totally is you know um
well i mean mental
mental performance right yeah absolutely
but but listen
if if you're if your kid doesn't get
into
harvard and another kid on
on adderall gets into harvard is that
cheating
is that it's a performance enhancing
drug right i don't know i think it's an
interesting
i think it's an interesting uh uh
argument i do know one of my favorite
onion headlines of all time was um
adderall receives honorary degree from
harvard law
which really speaks because because how
do you get through harvard law i guess
without uh
without without bumping those addies
right right well it's interesting like
like
like like saying a lot of people that i
know
especially young people that do cocaine
regularly really shocked me
it shocked me just as much of the amount
of people that do adderall
daily every single day like i was
talking to a girl
my wife's friend and she said she's been
prescribed adderall since she was 12
taking it every day of her life
rice [ __ ] poison it's a narcotic it's
a controlled substance for fun
and and and who the [ __ ] came up with
the i mean what a great
uh propaganda sales pitch to say
adderall cures adhd
or if adhd is even a real thing do they
just come up with that to sell adderall
i first of all part of the reason why
i've never tried cocaine
is not simply the illegality well i
think the expense was probably
it was cost it's cost prohibitive i
don't know how do you get a bunch of
rich friends in tampa who can afford
cocaine
um i guess it's cheaper now than it was
when i was you know when i when i was a
kid but like
um you know i also i'm like you like you
don't strike me as a guy who needs
cocaine
i guess nobody needs cocaine but like
i'm sort of
you know i'm a caffeine cowboy that's my
drug of choice and
i didn't start drinking until i was 21
years old that's that's what a
straight arrow i i was now i've been
making up for lost time mind you but you
know
you know and i gotta say when i tried
pot i didn't like it at all really
yeah the first like i kept saying well i
kept saying like
i'd rather be drunk i'd rather be drunk
ideas didn't slip you a couple
milligrams when you hung out with them
i didn't i didn't like this at all and i
i remember i i remember saying
you know what i said i was i said to my
cousin who was one of the first
marijuana medical marijuana
entrepreneurs out
west you know out in colorado got one of
the earliest licenses became
as you can imagine extremely successful
um i said to him
when i tried it with him as one of his
you know uh from one of his
dispensaries uh when it went wreck um i
said
this will never catch on that's what i
said to him
this will never catch up this is in 2017
i said this this [ __ ] will never cat no
one's gonna do that but i will tell you
this
went to chick-fil-a and i was like
oh i kind of get it like
because that [ __ ] tasted good man i mean
oh yeah
smoked you in there oh yeah
but i don't know i i just like what's
what i met someone
i remember being in new york years ago
many years ago um
i felt 15 or so years ago and was having
a conversation
with a woman and
i was like what is happening she is
all over the place and
i said it to someone i was like what is
she okay like this is
they're like oh you know she's she just
went into went to the bathroom she's
high as [ __ ]
and i was like holy [ __ ] and that's when
i realized
um i describe it this way i said
when when people are on cocaine they
start one sentence
and they finish another yes and you and
i are already like
you know i think half person like you're
right they would like have to scrape us
off the roof with a [ __ ]
shovel if we did cook it like we would
just you know we'd be like len biased
our faces would explode like if we
[ __ ] did
like what would i what would i do with
that enter where would i put that you
know i don't even
and that scared me like i thought like
oh my heart's just going to explode out
of my
out of my chest if i if i tried and i've
never been particularly curious
uh about it either and i think part of
the reason is maybe this is part of the
reason why i only smoked in
in colorado from like a a legit
dispensary
like down here in miami who the [ __ ]
knows what they're cutting this [ __ ]
with
i mean you take ecstasy god only knows
what this
what this anonymous person in a cl you
know like you could be
you could be [ __ ] you you got you'd
be deter if you're lucky it's baby
powder
but it could be detergent fentanyl like
it's just there's just
there's so much crazy [ __ ] out there
there's so many entrepreneurial hustlers
who are trying to say you know we're
trying to you know uh maximize the uh
you know their uh their profits that
they'll cut anything
in there that that's that's scary to me
like not knowing
like what the [ __ ] i just bought from
some stranger in a dark club for i don't
know
yeah no it's for sure and you know
obviously legalizing it makes it so much
more making it illegal just makes it 10
times more dangerous
oh dangerous not only the substance it
brings in
it brings in everything that prohibition
brings in it brings in the criminality
it brings in the you know the money
laundering it brings in of course yeah
like no regulation on the ingredients
and so god
no there's no listen there's no question
about it the the only
and it's the only way also to
effectively
create that many new jobs and a new
multi-billion dollar industry overnight
and i think statistically we know from
as marijuana both medical and
recreational is legalized
there's no statistical jump in the
number in
the number of people who use it meaning
people who want marijuana who want to
use marijuana
are not being deterred by prohibition
they're still
finding a way to get it regardless or
irregardless as we say in miami
um you know but like so when you
legalize it it's not like suddenly
everybody who's never done pod or does
it rushes out to try it or do it all
that like
you know there are there gonna be a few
people who will say oh let now maybe
i'll
try but they're not gonna if that's not
a huge number and they don't become
regular
you know customers or users um it just
doesn't make any sense why and again
this is sort of a another one of those
issues that i think should really
unite the left and right you know the
conservative which is like
you know which is like why why does the
government care
if i inhale a plant that grows out of
the earth that is less dangerous than
poison ivy
what do what does the government care
about that